[Music]
a man laces his sister's wedding cake
with marijuana to get guests high as
kites that's not cool cause panic
attacks it's cool but it's not cool a
wedding
if it's like a stoner wedding yeah yeah
but if there are people here that don't
watch too quickly we don't know in a
cheech and chong movie that's cool
in real life it's a little bit [ __ ]
way
my [ __ ] grandmother's tripping balls
like over there in the corner and like
throwing up not so cool yeah what about
the little kids tripping balls throwing
up maybe not yeah maybe not yeah for the
whole family wedding guests in chile
were high on more than love at a
reception this year
after the bride's brother laced her cake
with marijuana is that not illegal like
do you think he baked it or do you think
he just had a [ __ ] like thc oil just
drizzled all over it mixed it into the
uh
it was baked
so he did it
it was a green cake
alvaro rodriguez age 29 from santiago
chile he made the cake creating a
multi-tiered wedding cake and
celebrating with his sister when she got
married in february rodriguez made
reference to the special ingredient in
the cake which read
the return of the magic brownie 2.0
rodriguez spent 20 hours making and
decorating the cake which was covered in
white icing and flowers and at first
looked like an
uh entirely regular beautiful wedding
cake let me show you a photo of this 20
hours is this a baker there we go i love
how this guy was thinking oh they're
going to love this [ __ ] that's
a nice cake cool that's a big ass
[ __ ] cake though that's a lot of
[ __ ] oil that's a lot of hemp he
probably spent a lot of money on that
did it taste like weed it always does it
always does everything for sure
you go to a weed shop and they're like
this is blueberry pie and i'm like it's
weed
it is wheat with hints of blueberries
what are you talking about yeah it's
weed with a hint of blueberries
with like pepper of blueberry on it like
give you the edibles actually taste like
weed i don't know
i yeah like maybe i can't taste it it's
got a tinge to it like an aftertaste
some are better than others but most of
the time like they taste like it's like
eating an armpit
it's been a while since i ate an edible
but i don't even remember it tasting
like weed because i was so high
did you have wheat brownies before
cookies cookies did it taste like
cookies or tastes like cookies yeah like
[ __ ] chocolate chip regular whoa
[ __ ] you for [ __ ] my narrative
i don't believe
we've talked about this here before
right we have i think we talked about
edibles here
i told that one story about how i got
really [ __ ] up what was your story oh
it was either the one in amsterdam where
i was yeah you did talk about yeah
yeah yeah this one where you're [ __ ]
a girl with two [ __ ]
this one where you killed that guy all
right so have you guys tried an edible
uh gummy yes does that taste like wheat
it tastes like a gummy but it has an
essence of weed how about uh
brownie absolutely a good
cake yes
but but again a cake actually actually i
think when it's sweeter it's easier to
hide how about a cookie cookie you could
taste it right it's more savory actually
rice krispie treats uh hides it'll look
goodbye i think right inside right now
he just
rides high right now he was choking on a
kitkat
because
because steve said the two [ __ ]
ryan's straight edge guys so he can't
even imagine what that's like it's like
two absolutely closer imagine the two
[ __ ] and i am just having a little
bit of off camera ryan did do a spit
take of kitkats he was like two [ __ ]
so this dude alvaro did make it clear
just to know he did make it clear that
he made the adult guests aware that one
of tears offered the chance to get a bit
more than sugar rush thanks to the
inclusion of marijuana which is illegal
for all production and public
consumption in chile but legal for
private at-home consumption uh was this
at his home this is i think within the
realm of private okay homecoming he's
baking it in his kitchen
[Laughter]
the baker explained the inspiration for
the cake came after he and his sister
tried magical brownies and found the
effect to be very funny
this is this is good science goodbyes
so he's like man my sister liked it then
she probably would like it at her whole
wedding
and everything is brilliant that's a
little bit i'm a good gift giver this
guy comes from
he has a he has a good heart this guy he
said he didn't think twice when his
sister asked him to add weed to one of
the tears of her cake so she asked for
him okay well then consent but he went
overboard saying that particular level
took him two hours and was pretty easy
he said i just infused it with the
butter from the day before and once the
brownie set i put it with the other
levels with chocolate ganoush
and voila and voila
what i didn't realize was i was so high
that i thought that the whole cake
needed it too
i thought this guy had like a dispensary
and he goes man i gotta get some i gotta
do something big it's a buzz you know
yeah like he's got a rep pso pull
and for the whole kids thing he's at
rodriguez assured the special layer was
kept apart from the unlaced cake and was
only served to adults expressing belief
that cannabis cooking should be
normalized a little more both in
culinary and medical terms and he said
that the funniest reaction came from his
aunt who had been suffering with back
pain prior to having a piece of the
magic and it doesn't hurt anymore he
said i remember her back hurt and two
hours after eating cake her pain
disappeared and she was dancing like a
tv seen doing windmills
cannabis has incredible effects on those
who might need an alternative both for
physical and mental health
doctor dudes my friend she was uh she
was making some uh bud cookies and then
she went to step out real quick come
back her mom was like oh [ __ ] these are
[ __ ] bacon in the oven oh no she
takes it out right and then she's like
ooh fresh cookies starts pounding them
down
when she gets home she sees her mom with
a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] of cookies cracking
the [ __ ] up watching a korean drama
that's pretty good and then she was like
oh [ __ ] and then so she slowly tiptoed
away and just let her mom just [ __ ]
laugh her ass off and pass away
pass away
oh
[Applause]
you thought weed wasn't the gateway drug
guess what we just killed you
[ __ ] reefer madness over here yeah
that'll be next level by the way this
was brought to you by pfizer
[Laughter]
mind was blown right now dude just
walked away and let her pass away yeah
what a difference one word can you say
that
she [ __ ] poisoned her mom to death
with weed
and to be tip-toeing away from us
her feet was sealed
she already knew it was too late for her
she kissed her mom on the forehead went
to bed yeah and she already knew she's
going doing what she loves
she died doing what she loves watching
soap operas and getting hot
laughing her ass off
oh my god was there any ill uh effects
from anybody was anybody vomiting just
loss of back pain there were definitely
like uh there's there's a short video
let me see if i can pull it someone felt
their heart beating people were for sure
um dancing and i think that's an amazing
effect right especially once you start
getting the high you definitely start
having a really good time you start
dancing but in case you eat a little too
much there's usually a follow-up after
effect let's see if we can oh no
were the people yeah paranoia i get too
high
what's this all day
all night
all day
you take [ __ ] this [ __ ] all day yeah all
night
mostly aggressive music all night
i'll turn off the music just in case you
know that's him he's like yeah
one hour later uh-huh he's checking out
people starting to dance he said my
auntie is
after her food yeah
after after dinner this place they come
in
everybody's dancing and then two hours
later
is everyone sleeping
everybody's still eating because they
got the munchies oh no so they got even
higher
and then vomiting
just when they watched dude where's my
car
and everybody was super chill afterwards
to be fair i think the idea of having a
[ __ ] ton of people who willingly yeah
when they are when they are given the
option and willingly partake
that's gotta be a sick ass wedding
especially for dancing how much per luna
we'll all do it together how much we'll
get for luna well we'll all get [ __ ]
up together oh like when luna hits this
price you want to do edibles or you want
to smoke that's easy for me i'll [ __ ]
do if luna goes down i'll smoke right
now
let's do it
smoke to cope how much for the rum i
know you're probably going to be
straight edge christian about it i'll
replace it with something just as
destructive there you go like what he'll
have a squeeze so he should be the
actual measure when luna's what price
would you be would you throw a banana i
don't know we like that he's going to
spend a lot of money on apps
on app
yeah
i'll just do that i'll just buy a new
[ __ ] um
[ __ ] sword
he got his whole crypto corner to say
that when luna hits 120 they all have to
buy kindergarten noodles
i never said that that i would never say
i totally said it unusual hundred two
dollars
now we're gonna we'll do it live we'll
do it
oh yo yeah you should [ __ ] have
everybody like [ __ ] send a screenshot
of their order to you and then you'll do
like a [ __ ] cat and then what they're
all going to throw it in the trash can
right big old steve makes it safe
bro you [ __ ] move product amazon be
like yeah you're all going to fill up
our trash cans however and i respect how
people fill up the trash cans i fill up
mine up in a certain way
mine stays too empty it's kind of hard
to fill it up with just two people no
bad publicity right yeah i guess sales
would you buy it just to throw it away
yeah what if you're what if your
business got like super successful just
from people like throwing it away from
doing the kinja bank challenge which you
made like millions of [ __ ] dollars
it's a pet rock of yours
what if the slogan becomes so good you
don't even have to eat it
so good just toss it yeah yeah so good
it's good for your garbage can
wow that's really interesting garbage
cans love it
it's like it like maybe somebody opens
your garbage cans like
oh
it's get that kindred baby
that's your garbage can been eating king
chubby
it's got that little kitchen bag touch
to it with your garbage can
honey what's that it's like well babe
i had decided to feed our garbage can
kitchen bag
well
i
shut the [ __ ] up
that's just stupid
i like throwing kitchen bag in the
packaging away
that is the job
bizarro world thing to do
120 we'll do it live we'll do it live
that's pretty soon did you get new
scented hefty bags something like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you